>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Grant Harris: Welcome
to the European Division
Library of Congress.
And I'm Grant Harris.
I'm head of the European
Reading Room.
And we're very pleased to have Paul
Miller here today to talk to us
on -- I don't have actually in
front of me -- there it is --
Warn the Duke: The
Sarajevo Assassination
in History, Memory, and Myth.
And I apologize for not
having a larger room.
I should have known that Paul
Miller's star power would bring a
large group in here.
I've always been impressed
with Paul's lectures.
And that's true.
So I'd just like to say
Paul is at McDaniel College,
an associate professor there.
His PhD is in modern European
history at Yale University.
His dissertation, From
Revolutionaries to Citizens:
Anti-Militarism in
France, 1870-1914.
And that was published
by Duke University Press.
In 2004 and 2005 he was a Fulbright
fellow at the University of Sarajevo
where he wrote on and
taught genocide issues.
From 2011 to 2013, Paul was a Marie
Curie fellow at the University
of Birmingham in England
where he researched
and later published
his work on the Memory
of the Sarajevo Assassination.
And I've been very pleased that
I was able to include Paul Miller
in a talk we had a couple years
back, I think, a panel discussion
on Sarajevo in this building.
And I'm pleased that we
have him here again to talk.
And so I'll just turn this
over now to you, Paul.
Thank you for being here.
>> Paul Miller: Yeah,
thank you very much, Grant.
[ Applause ]
Yeah. And thanks to your terrific
staff here for organizing this.
And thank you all for coming
on a Friday afternoon.
Grant actually said to me, "Is
there any way you could tie this
in with an American theme?"
So first of all, I should
draw attention to the fact
that Franz Ferdinand is a
band, some of you already know.
So hence, this is a band poster.
The band has nothing to do with
the Sarajevo assassination,
per se; they're in Scotland.
But this is already not working.
Oh, because I have to turn it on.
How do I turn it on?
I'm sorry.
Ah, there it is.
Okay. So as an American theme,
I thought what better to start
with than the Jewish
Hungarian-American Harry Houdini?
And there he is, doing
one of his escape acts,
the famous magician escape artist.
The very day Franz Ferdinand and his
wife were shot to death in Sarajevo,
the world-famous magician Harry
Houdini was hanging upside
down in a straight jacket 12 stories
over New York City's Times Square.
Here's another picture.
The ecstatic crowd was
holding its collective breath
as the escape artist performed one
of his most audacious
and dangerous acts.
4,000 miles away, another energized
crowd was ravaging Serb property
in the Bosnian capital.
There, too, if less literally,
danger was in the air.
But even Houdini was not
above the milieu as he dangled
above Midtown Manhattan; on the
contrary, the great conjurer was
in the midst of quote, "The
one genuine mystical experience
of his life," end quote.
It came in the form of a
memory triggered by news
of the archduke's assassination.
From inside the straight
jacket's darkness,
Houdini suddenly visualized a
scene from six summers earlier
when on a Sunday drive through
the New York suburbs his auto had
overheated just opposite a house
where a little boy
was playing outside.
While the liveried chauffeur
refilled the radiator,
the legendary illusionist had
refreshed his thirst inside
with the family.
It was as he was leaving that the
now-remembered moment occurred.
The boy, entranced like all children
by the magician, had followed him
into the street and was
standing before the car,
staring at his distorted
macrocephalic reflection
in the shiny brass
fitting of the headlight.
"Goodbye, sonny," said Houdini.
"Warn the duke," replied the boy.
Then he ran off.
The magician had not given the
cryptic utterance a single thought
since, not even when he met
the Archduke Franz Ferdinand
at an air show in Germany
a year later.
So this is exactly the kind of story
that the American writer
E.L. Doctorow likes to insert
into his fiction, one in which
cosmic design lurks just beneath the
outward, arbitrary look of things,
and the characters themselves
remain largely oblivious to it.
In his work Ragtime, as in the
Sarajevo assassination, accident
and intention intersected at the
very spot Houdini's car sputtered
and swerved in the curve.
But when the little boy,
who happens to live there,
transmits an authentic
message from beyond,
the imminent illusionist
fails to recognize it.
Thus missing the signal from
a real-life mystic, the boy,
the fake one -- Houdini -- forfeits
his chance to change history
by alerting Franz Ferdinand
and averting the flashpoint
of global catastrophe.
Only at the end of the novel
on the day the duke is murdered
and the moment Houdini
is immobilized
in midair does the magician sense
that he may have been tripped
up by something truly magical.
As far as we know, there
was nothing supernatural
about the Sarajevo assassination.
And yet, every aspect of it has
a whiff of the otherworld --
from the many warnings
the archduke did receive
to the way events unfolded that day,
the barely evaded bomb, for example,
the fact that Count Harrach got on
the running board later in the day
to protect Franz Ferdinand
but he was on the wrong side.
And the famous wrong turn
that you've all heard about.
Franz Ferdinand himself had a
superstitious streak once relating
how a fortune teller had
prophesied that he would quote
"Someday unleash a world war."
But the archduke was above
all an ardent Catholic, who,
whenever given a grim account
of the security situation,
confidently fell back on his faith.
Quote, "Our lives are
constantly in danger,"
he told his [inaudible] chief
of staff on April 18th, 1913,
"One just has to trust
in God," end quote.
On June 28th, 1914 God clearly
was not on the successor's side.
Fate, destiny, design, doom --
these are the usual stuff of
memory rather than history.
They're also a big part of how we
process the Sarajevo assassination
and in the process transmute
it from historical event
into mythologized moment.
Fictional and figurative works like
Ragtime do this deliberately,
if at times subtly, inserting a
scene, phrase, image, character,
or storyline that alludes
to some aspect of Sarajevo
and then leaves readers to reflect
on meaning, assuming, that is,
that they haven't missed
the metaphor altogether.
Selden Edwards' successful novel --
fantasy novel The Little Book
is another interesting instance
of this.
While the work mainly tracks
a time-traveling teenager
from 1988 San Francisco
to 1897 Vienna,
it opens with a scene
evoking the very deed that in
so many depictions undid the
era that enraptures the author.
In the scene a 10-year-old
protagonist is walking
in the wilderness with his mother
when he spies a hawk hovering
at about 100-foot distance.
Reflexively, as little boys are
wont to be, he picks up a stone
and quote "In one beautifully
unified motion, wings it right
at the bird," which drops, quote,
"Like an over-ripe
peach," end quote.
His mother is aghast.
The boy is totally stunned.
He can't believe he even came
close, let alone laid the bird out.
And he's seized by a strange
sense of shame and awe, quote,
"It was hard to explain,
but something began
to dawn on him in that moment.
He had felt for just an
instance the connectedness
of all things," end quote.
The alert reader might well wonder
whether the Gavrilo Princip also
experienced such mystical
connectedness
when his shots hit home or more
likely was he clobbered so quickly
by the crowd that he had
no chance to feel anything?
Whatever the upshot, Selden
Edwards could have left his audience
to its own imaginings.
Yet just to be sure that
we all got the allegory,
he inserts what the boy's mother
hopes will be a life lesson
for her thunderstruck son, quote,
"That such tiny and thoughtless acts
of violence were exactly what
eventually caused the huge
consequences of world
war," end quote.
The author's choice of adjectives
is interesting -- tiny, thoughtless.
Certainly in relation to the
First World War, the assassination
of a single archduke, even
if he were heir to the throne
of the Austro-Hungarian
Empire, may well appear trivial.
Yet in its proper geopolitical
context,
Sarajevo was nothing less
than earth-shattering.
After all, it had been barely five
years since Austria's annexation
of Bosnia led to the Bosnian crisis,
which almost led to a European war.
And in light of the nationalist
feelings in the region
and Serbia's accelerated irredentism
since the two Balkan wars in 1912
and 1913, no one had any illusions
as to the danger the archduke
courted when he went to Bosnia,
let alone drove through its
capital in a convertible
on a Serb national holiday.
The emperor himself had
been stalked by an assassin
when he visited Bosnia
four years earlier.
His nephew's murder there four years
later was anything but thoughtless;
it was a highly purposeful
act of political violence.
Yet rather than censure the
novelist, Selden Edwards,
whose artistic license arguably
allows him some factual leeway,
academics and other assumed experts
have contributed to the construction
of the assassination as
tiny and thoughtless.
Around the time of the centenary two
years ago in the New York Times,
the Oxford historian
Margaret McMillan referred
to the political murder
as quote, "A random event
in an Austro-Hungarian
backwater" end quote.
And pre-dating this perspective
there's 100-year history
of reducing Sarajevo to fate,
fluke, chance, and accident
and the city itself, along with
Bosnia and the Balkans in general,
to obscure savage, primitive,
remote, and in a word irrelevant,
quote "A ridiculous mouse" --
the Sarajevo assassination --
that it probably induced,
quote, "Towering mountain ranges
into labor," wrote
one British scholar.
In the 1930's an American
journalist decreed it quote,
"An intolerable affront to
human and political nature
that these parochial, and
miserable, and wretched,
and shriveled little countries in
the Balkans can and do have quarrels
that cause world wars," end quote.
The same holds for the randomness
issue, Princip intentions.
There's no shortage of
scholarly works that use language
which easily lends
itself to the notion
that sheer coincidence
brought Franz Ferdinand face
to face with his assassin.
According to Yale historian
and my mentor,
John Merriman's highly
successful textbook,
A History of Modern Europe,
"Princip just happened
to be only a few feet from the
archduke's car," end quote.
The historian Hew Strachan, one of
the great historians of World War I
in his book, The First World
War, the assassin was quote,
"Loitering on the corner when the
successor's car suddenly appeared."
And in an article published -- I
can give you thousands of examples.
In an article published in the
recent issue of the Journal
of Modern History,
the author writes
that the Gavrilo Princip
was quote, "Milling about,
ruminating on his group's
failed attempt
when the car suddenly stopped
right in front of him."
Besides the author's sense that
he can read the assassin's mind,
the historian, as many before him,
also seems to have
overlooked the fact
that Princip was doing his
milling about or his loitering
at the precise spot the procession
was supposed to turn according
to the well-publicized itinerary.
That's why Princip
was standing there.
Not to mention the fact that he had
a gun and a grenade in his pocket.
But was he also eating a sandwich,
as the 2003 BBC documentary Days
That Shook the World
first reported?
Well, in case you haven't heard, the
conspirators called off their effort
after the bomb missed its
mark, but Gavrilo Princip,
understandably starving
from spending, you know,
the morning in the hot summer sun,
headed to Mortiz Schiller's
Delicatessen for a bite to eat.
And here two destinies
collided to steer history
in its diabolic direction as
Princip turned up from his lunch
to see the car stalled
squarely in front of him.
The only question is why the
half-eaten sandwich never made it
into a museum and obviously
what kind of sandwich it was.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
It's not as whimsical as it sounds.
One teacher offered his students
extra credit if they could find
out what kind of sandwich it was.
By the way, all my students incoming
now have heard the sandwich story.
That wasn't true ten
years ago, but now it is.
And besides classrooms, the story
has seeped into serious works.
One historian, A Concise History
of Western Civilization --
this is a historian published
by a serious academic press,
2011 -- has the sandwich.
Nicholas Rankin's Oxford
University Press published book
on British cunning in the two world
wars, Gavrilo Princip is quote,
"Consoling himself with a sandwich
when the archduke drops in."
And I can give you
lots more examples
of serious university-publisher
books.
Quote, "Whoever made the sandwich
Gavrilo Princip ate on June 28th,
1914 has a lot to answer for," reads
the first sentence of an article
in the Los Angeles Times by the
science writer for Time magazine.
Indeed they do.
In the case of the sandwich, the
myth moved in the other direction,
that is, the story first appeared in
a Brazilian novel that just happened
to be translated into English
at the same time the BBC director
was working on his documentary.
In other words, you can't
find before 2003 any reference
to a sandwich.
Only in 2003 and after
the BBC documentary comes
out that you start seeing
references to him eating a sandwich
as the archduke's car pulls up.
In this novel, by the way,
a 12-fingered trained
assassin inserts himself
into the signal events
of the 20th century.
And on June 28th, 1914,
the well-endowed protagonist
encounters Gavrilo Princip
in Sarajevo and he's eating
sandwich in the novel.
So in these and other
ways, then, nonfiction
and even scholarly
writing contributed
to the assassination's mythization
through an inviting infusion
of exaggerated language,
interpretive overreach
like inbred Balkan barbarism,
the inevitable collapse
of a European order, etc.,
recurring canards like the sandwich,
and rhetoric that leads readers
directly from that hot sunny day
in Sarajevo to those cold muddy
trenches of the western front.
In this regard, quote, "The first
shots of the First World War,"
end quote is a catchy
and compelling way
to describe the archduke's
peacetime political murder.
The expression has thus
appeared in countless contexts
and configurations and
through all the cultural
and political upheaval
of the past century.
Its ubiquity, however,
does not make it true.
What it makes it is memorable.
In parallel manner, Houdini's
personal recollection
of the little boy becomes the
shared memory of the millions
who read Ragtime, a novel
that is not even about Sarajevo,
the Sarajevo assassination as such.
What Doctorow's classic -- and
if you haven't read Ragtime,
please do, it's just terrific like
all of Doctorow's novels, I think.
What his novel's about, race
and the roiling tensions
in American identity during the
transformative years before the
First World War is
realized and enlivened
by the author's intrepid
combination of actual history --
right, Houdini existed -- and
overt invention, the boy didn't.
Most notably, all the characters,
whether fictional like the boy
or historical like Houdini, are
interconnected in a chaotic pattern
of coincidence, correspondence,
and as we've seen, occult.
Such a setup seems ready-made
for Sarajevo, whose maddening mix
of randomness -- the wrong
turn, and predictably --
all the warnings that did happen --
readily provokes a common comforting
assumption that because it happened,
it somehow had to and so, too,
the great power collision itself.
The novel thus taps into two
of the assassination's truly
mythical registers of remembrance --
that it improbably occurred
in this preposterous place
and that it directly gave rise
to the inevitable great war.
So a little theory now
because this is memory study,
so I can't really get
away from it, right?
Ultimately, of course, it's the
latter that matters in terms
of the measureless
attention we place
on this particular political murder.
Were it not for the
unforetold global fallout
from Franz Ferdinand's fatality,
then Doctorow's Houdini would not
have been told to warn the duke,
right, whose death would merely have
joined the long and lugubrious list
of political murders
that marked the era.
If Princip's pistol shots
were not literally the first
of the First World War, they were
outrageously what triggered the
crisis that came to it.
It's precisely this absurd asymmetry
that makes Sarajevo the epitome
of what the historian Pierre
Nora calls a spectacular event,
one quote, "On which posterity
retrospectively confers the
greatness of origins, the
solemnity of inaugural ruptures.
Thus the assassination can be
considered a lieux de memoire,
a site of memory supremely suited to
contemplating this consequent past."
Now, for Pierre Nora, such sites
were typically physical spaces
with national subtexts.
And the one where Princip pulled
the trigger can certainly be studied
as such.
But for our purposes
it's the act itself
which suffuses popular memory, just
like the lethal limo is displayed
in a museum, and there it is.
I don't know who that
kid is [Laughs].
That's my nephew, it's her brother.
And just as we crack up clumsily
every time the comic explains quote,
"Franz Ferdinand found alive;
World War I a mistake."
As these select examples suggest,
what we commonly compartmentalize
as history or memory are
not necessarily polarized
in the ways we might presume.
This point was not
always so problematic.
Only with the emergence of modernity
in the 19th century did scholars
begin stressing the strict schism
between history and memory.
Unlike in earlier epochs
when traditional forms
of imparting the past invariably
conflated these concepts --
people used to pass down history
as stories, right, inflating memory
and history -- history now in the
19th century modernity came to stand
for quote, "An ideal of
disinterested objectivity,
while memory was increasingly
regarded as inherently subjective."
Then came post-modernism
in the late 1970's
with its direct challenge
to objective truth.
And soon enough, historians
were pointing to ways
in which their own discipline was
beset by subjectivities conditioned
by the confines of
language and context.
Yet rather than belaboring it,
they built upon this insight
to begin making a cultural
turn as it's called
in academic milieu towards
studying historical representation.
So now monuments and museums,
commemorative acts, rituals,
and even street names were
avenues for interpreting the past.
Everything from fiction to folklore,
film, art, images, textbooks,
even children's books became fair
game for ferreting out meaning.
And in this expansive sense,
then, narrative history itself --
part of my argument --
can also serve as a source
for surveying representation,
one that's informed and deforms
in ways strikingly similar
to its alleged other memory.
Make no mistake, I am an historian.
History is still history in
that its intrinsic intention
is understanding.
Memory has no such motive.
Oh, I should say history may
never be perfectly objective,
but it strives for empirical truth.
Memory has no such motive.
Steeped in meaning, it feeds on
our feelings rather than intellect,
preys upon passions as
opposed to answering questions.
That's why memory is regularly
associated with place,
such as the actual site of
the Sarajevo assassination.
Politics in time period two
can radically transform how
and what we remember,
which is why the site
of the assassination
has seen five memorials
and three museums in one century.
Of course, history
writing is also influenced
by temporal and political context.
Just witness the number of recent
studies drawing direct analogies
to terrorism today, and
there are a ton of examples.
But the example I'm going
to give is the one that came
to my attention the most
recently not by an historian
but in the New York Times
by Roger Cohen four days ago.
"The Orlando killer, Omar
Mateen, is the Gavrilo Princip
of the early 21st century.
Like the 19-year-old Bosnian Serb
nationalist whose bullets ignited
World War I, Mateen has set a spark
to a time of inflammable anger,"
says Roger Cohen in the New
York Times just a few days ago.
So there you have -- this is the
line I gave a little earlier.
And this is an academic
book [foreign language]
in Austrian Academic Press.
And you see paired the
World Trade Center in flames
and the Sarajevo assassination.
Okay. So if the world changed
forever on September the 11th, 2001,
then what the heck happened
on the 28th instance
of June 1914 at 10:50
in the morning?
This is the title of a film which
I would venture few scholars
of the war's origins have ever
heard of, let alone actually seen.
That's because it has
nothing whatsoever to do
with the event it's plainly evoking.
Rather, this work is a portrait
of two modern gay artists who are
so inspired by the Victorian Era
that they have turned their
entire life work into artwork,
living without contemporary
conveniences whatsoever --
no cells phones --
surrounding themselves
with a 19th century repertoire
of furniture, photographs,
musical instruments,
dress, utensils,
and even historical objects
conserved under glass.
According to the film's website,
the documentary film
demonstrates the extent
to which the artists'
lives are subservient
to their quasiphilosophical
conception of time.
We thus watch them emptying piss
pots, mending vintage clothing,
and pecking away on
manual typewriters
like the one I learned to type on.
And yet, these scenes are all set in
the midst of modern-day Manhattan.
So what can we make of this work
in the context of coming to terms
with the Sarajevo assassination?
Is its title merely an
attention-grabbing gimmick?
By so methodically imposing
the past onto the present,
are these artists actually just
overnostalgic escapists naive
to the 19th century's
gross inequities,
which it would have made
their lives together
as middle class gay men
impossible in the first place?
That's certainly one way to see it.
Yet I would suggest there's
something about the preserved past
in the present lives
of Peter McGough
and David McDermott that's decidedly
exhilarating, not because we want
to go back but because we might
have done better with the world.
Time is determinative.
And its displacement here highlights
the radical change that has occurred
in the last century, the one
that can be conveniently dated
to the precise moment that Princip's
bullet pierced the heir's bull neck
and blood spurted onto his tunic,
which is also displayed
today in a museum.
The blood's fading.
It's a moment, moreover, that a
wide range of writers, artists,
and others have regularly
constructed in terms
of a definitive break with an
idyllic world or directly blamed
for having brought on
all the bad in this one.
Some of the most amusing examples
-- and here I'm just going to throw
out a few examples -- are murder
mysteries and related fiction
that focuses on solving the
crime and saving humanity
by stopping the Sarajevo
assassination.
There are also nonfiction
works that do this.
Robert Goddard's classic
thriller Closed Circle,
two World War I veterans find
out that there was a conspiracy
by some very rich financiers to
start a world war and, therefore,
they would become even richer.
And they're trying to
track down this conspiracy.
There's a counterfictional work
that I'm hoping will be
translated into English.
It was written in German, it's
called The Comet in English.
And it's a terrific read.
It's got excellent reviews.
It just came out a few years ago.
And in the world that's woven
in this book, Franz Ferdinand,
after the assassination attempt
that fails, earlier in the morning,
the bomb, he says,
"Oh, what the heck?
Let's go home," goes back to Vienna.
Vienna and Berlin, of
course, there's no holocaust,
so they have their Jewish
populations have become the capitals
of the world and America
remains cowboy
and Indian land, totally primitive.
And he weaves this whole tale
about how the world develops.
It's hilarious.
Kids books do this a lot, too.
Actually, my nephew,
I gave him this book
by a British writer Johnny O'Brien,
Jack Christie's Adventures,
and one of them is the Day of
the Assassins in which two people
who invent a time machine
go back to try
to prevent the Sarajevo
assassination.
But one decides that no,
they shouldn't change history
because then we wouldn't exist and
other positive things that happened
in the world wouldn't happen.
And they have this big
argument about whether
or not history should be changed.
So there's millions
of examples like this.
Here's another example that gets
us back to the American theme,
F. Scott Fitzgerald's short
story The Ice Palace
in which there's an oblique
reference to quote, "the Serbia,"
quote, "an unknown man who had
not had his trousers pressed,"
end quote.
Tellingly, the Serbia's identity
is irrelevant to what transpires
when this baggy-pantsed man
is spotted on a street corner
by the story's protagonists --
a northerner, think back to the
time period Fitzgerald's writing --
a northerner named Harry and his
fiancee from the south, Sally.
Now, this is long before
When Harry Met Sally.
So nothing to do with the film.
Harry, mischievous --
Harry's from the north --
he mischievously reckons
the raggedly figure
on the street corner a southerner,
then launches into a litany
of stereotypes about
this whole quote,
"Hang dog lot of sordid degenerates
who've gotten lazy and shiftless
from living so long
among colored people."
Sally, the southerner,
can't bear to hear this.
And what readers then witness is
a clash of worldviews so severe
as to bring the betrothed
to the brink
of a dangerously steep
quarrel or war, right?
All because of some
slovenly man in the street
in Harry's wholesome hometown, a
stand-in, it seems safe to assume,
for the unkempt miscreant
who murdered the archduke
and plunged the world, the
marriage into Armageddon.
Similarly, the American writer
Askold Melnyczuk's novel What is
Told, the protagonist
just happened to get married
on the day the archduke is murdered.
The priests -- nobody
really pays attention.
The priest kind of grumbles
about the bad weather that day.
But once the war comes
and the husband is killed,
the young wife swears revenge
against the Serbian prince.
She says in the novel, "Who
do these men think they were
that she should lose a
husband for their sakes?"
So that may be quasimythical,
but it's also an eloquent part
of the painful legacy these writers
are struggling with, that is,
it's much easier to target
the Sarajevo assassination
than the World War's true culprits,
the leaders of Europe's great
powers -- all men, by the way.
And therein lies one myth that
has made the Sarajevo murder
so memorable, its causal culmination
in the First World War with all
that conflict's concomitant
consequences from the demise of men
to the rise of despots in the
destruction of civilization.
Here's some quotes, "Except for
Sarajevo, writers and scholars both
around the world actually, across
the century, Europe's," quote --
this is a scholar --
"ascending process
of civilized well-being
would not have been broken,"
except for the Sarajevo
assassination.
Dialogue on women's rights
would never have been deferred,
except for the Sarajevo
assassination.
Gandhi's colonial emancipation
could not have happened,
except for the Sarajevo
assassination.
Chicago Tribune, 1937,
two Serbian assassinations
and an American massacre.
Okay? And who hasn't heard of
the quote unquote "the sofa"
on which one could
lay the 20th century?
That's the sofa that the
archduke died upon and for
which the Austrian
government paid a lot of money
in the 1990's to put in the museum.
There it is.
It's more like a chaise
lounge, I guess.
The Museum of Military
History in Vienna,
Austrian Museum of Military History.
[Inaudible] museum in German.
The man who made that purchase,
Dr. Manfried Rauchensteiner,
did so as director of the Austrian
Museum of Military History,
which has an entire room
of assassination relics,
including the fateful auto.
Yet as an accomplished historian,
Rauchensteiner also reminds us
in one of his books,
quote, "That the murder
of Franz Ferdinand did not trigger
a war, but rather a European crisis.
And this crisis could
well have been resolved
without global conflagration
as discernibly graver ones
were earlier in the era."
Is there, then, enough
space in public memory
to include the failings and foibles
of those leaders truly at fault
for the World War,
or is it just easier
to proclaim Gavrilo Princip quote,
"The greatest murderer of all time,"
and assume that events
followed a preordained path,
or as the BBC documentary
stated in 1964,
"The peace of Europe died
with the royal pair."
In no case -- now I'm going to give
sort of a case study very quickly --
in no case, perhaps, has this
been more true than for Austria,
which not only lost the
World War but was forced
to for sake its 600-year-old
Hapsburg Empire.
Unsurprisingly, the suddenness
of the ageless empire's
disappearance gave rise to the type
of confusion that typically
takes refuge in nostalgia
as what one scholar called, "Old
Austrians looked back longingly,"
unquote, the loss of greatness,
harmony, and stability,
the end of an idyllic world
and enchanted middle
Europe, middle Europa.
For the great Austrian novelist
Stefan Zweig it was not the
armistice of November 11th,
1918; it was not the signing
of the Saing-Germain Treaty
on September 10th, 1919,
which officially dissolved the
Austro-Hungarian, which ended it.
No, it was June 28th,
1914 when, quote,
"In a single second this knowable
and dependable enchanted world
was smashed into a thousand pieces
like a hollow clay vessel."
Similarly, Austrian
efforts to come to terms
with Franz Ferdinand's unfinished
legacy have commonly constructed him
as the first victim of
the First World War.
And there's lots of quotes to this
effect, so I'm going to skip that.
There's never been a monument
or memorial to Franz Ferdinand
in Vienna, let alone a street
or a square named for him.
But he's been remembered in Austria
since 1934 in the castle gate
on Heroes' Square where you find
Austria's official World War
I memorial.
Okay? It's right there on the left.
So this is World War I
memorial, this is the Tomb
of the Unknown Soldier in Vienna.
This is right on Heroes' Square.
Anybody who knows Vienna's
been there.
So there. Archduke Franz
Ferdinand killed in Sarajevo.
Of course, there was no world
war going on when he was killed,
and that's sort of my point.
And in 1986 another marker went
up to in the Kaiser's Crypt.
Franz Ferdinand, for
various reasons having to do
with his morganatic wife,
is not buried in the Kaiser's
Crypt, the imperial crypt.
But they put a plaque up in 1986
in remembrance of Franz Ferdinand
and his wife, who was also killed,
in memory of the first
victims of the First World War.
So "Zum gedenken an die ersten opfer
des weltkrieges" is what it says
at the top.
Right? And here it is, and there's
Franz Joseph's tomb right there.
And so that's what it looks like.
And this is a tourist play; every
tourist goes to the Kaiser's Crypt
when they go to Vienna,
right, to see all these tombs
of the various emperors
and empresses.
If Austrian popular memory
could construct Franz Ferdinand
and his frau as the first
victims of the First World War,
then why not Sarajevo as the
place where the World War began?
When in 1927 the great Austrian
writer Joseph Roth went to Sarajevo,
he cannot quite bring
himself to wish ruin upon it.
"Why should I?
It has good people, beautiful women,
marvelously innocent children,
pets that are happy to be alive."
Yet neither could the author accept
Sarajevo's everyday ordinariness,
as he also wrote in the Frankfurter
newspaper Zeitung, "Nonetheless,
the war began here and
the world is wrecked.
And Sarajevo stands.
It should not be a city.
It should be a monument to make
everyone remember with horror."
While Sarajevo itself cannot be
held accountable for the World war,
such modes of remembrance remind us
that it cannot be separated
from it either.
Just as a story and sometimes
bookend the 20th century
between the Sarajevo assassination
and the city's siege in the 1990's
in order to create a neat,
explanatory framework for the forces
that shaped the era, writers
who reflect upon the city
in non-scholarly ways also end up
shaping its memory, though in ways
that are typically more
mythic than accurate.
Quote, "Look deeply into
the history of Sarajevo,"
wrote the Bosnian author
Hamza Humo in 1934,
"and you will find
a city characterized
by an atmosphere of protest."
For the author the assassination
of Franz Ferdinand was nothing less
than the heroic culmination
of a rebellious mentality
that had characterized the
Bosnian capital for centuries.
Now, contrast this
with a poem written
by the very well-known British
writer poet Lawrence Durrell
in 1951, and I'll read it.
"Where minarets have twisted up
like sugar in a river curdled
with blind ice drives on,
tinkling among the mule teams
and the mountaineers under the
bridges and the wooden trellises,
which tame the air and promises
us a peace -- excuse me --
harmless with nightingales,
none are singing now.
Know history much?
Perhaps. Only this ominous, dark
beauty flowering under veils,
trapped in the spectrum
of a dying style,
a village like an instinct
left to rust,
composed around the
echo of pistol shot."
For Durrell, not a
Bosnian, the assassination
and the ugly world war it
provoked are wholly at odds
with the deliciously serene
natural and prehistorical,
premodern landscape that
he finds in Sarajevo.
So which picture of
Sarajevo is correct?
Was it the fate of this peaceful
premodern city to become the site
of the most famous political
murder in modern history,
or was it completely in accord
with the Bosnian capital's
rebellious nature?
Of course, the answer is both
and neither, as these myths,
like all myths, say more about how
we try to make sense of the world
than they actually do about
the assassination itself.
In other words, when history and
memory blur, the myths that form
out of them are liable to
tell us more about ourselves
than what actually
historically happened.
So I'm wrapping up now.
What isn't the Sarajevo
assassination, if not a handy symbol
for however we wish to
make sense of the world?
Well, that's certainly
taking things too far.
And the point here is not
to strike an uncritical blow
at such construals as we've
seen in this talk; rather,
my aim to illustrate and
analyze the range of means
by which the archduke's
assassination has been incorporated
into our collective lexicon,
thus lending it the kind
of mythical quality that comes
from both too much attention
to the details -- the warnings,
the wrong turn, the sandwich --
and too little appreciation for
the larger historical context
in which the assassination occurred
and the truly decisive actions
that took place in its
immediate aftermath.
But as we all very well know,
history is always complicating
things.
And the origins of World War
I are very, very complicated.
Memory, on the other hand,
is what makes the past
really interesting and fun.
So an unforgettable finale.
There he is, back to Houdini.
In the end, 12 stories above
ground and upside down,
Houdini escaped the straight jacket.
Ta-da. In questions and
answers I can tell you how.
A feat of unbelievable physicality
that he performed regularly.
Escaping his own memory,
however, proved impossible.
Certainly, there was no way for the
magician to know that at this moment
of mental torment that
the death that day
of the duke he didn't
warn would affect each
and every person madly applauding
him in Midtown Manhattan,
not to mention most of
the rest of humanity.
Unless, of course, the
amazing Houdini really did have
mystical powers.
There's no hint of this in the
novel, though there is one thing
about the conjurer that
connects the coming calamity
to his troubling memory.
For all his renown, Doctorow's
Houdini detests himself.
Despite the prodigious talents
-- his prodigious talents --
he regards his professional work as
pure fakery and empty entertainment.
The legendary illusionist longs for
the kind of legitimacy we associate
with history rather than memory,
truth instead of trickery,
or as Houdini says in the novel,
quote, "There was a kind of act
that used the real world for its
stage -- he couldn't touch it.
For all his achievement,
he was a trickster,
an illusionist, a mere magician.
What was the sense of
his life if people walked
out of the theatre and forgot him?
The real world act was what got
into the history books," end quote.
Gavrilo Princip could
certainly attest to that.
What he did on the 28th
instance of June 1914
at 10:50 a.m. was definitely no
illusion, let alone an accident,
even if his opportunity to make
history arrived accidentally.
Moreover, not only did it get
into the Bosnian [inaudible]
into the textbooks and
smud-caked Sarajevo onto the maps,
in 1999 several people
crowned Princip, quote,
"The most important person in
the 20th century," end quote.
Single-handedly it has been said
Gavrilo Princip ended Europe's
Golden Age.
And for almost four decades
his footprints were set
into the pavement on
the street corner
that started the 20th century.
There's the footprints, and
there's the street corner
that started the 20th century.
Just like those of
Hollywood legends in front
of Grauman's Chinese Theatre in LA.
A museum was even devoted
to Princip's daring.
In 2014 Serbs erected two statues
of Princip and tourists flooded
into Sarajevo to hear the
Vienna Philharmonic try
to harmonize the past
with the present.
And it all happened because some
terminally ill student somehow found
himself at the right intersection
at the right millisecond,
all the while eating a sandwich.
Harry Houdini was right, his entire
life's work would never compete
with a real-world act
like the assassination
of Archduke Franz Ferdinand
-- it was much too magical.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Grant Harris: That's great.
I could hear bits and
pieces as I tried
to get more people
into the room here.
I think we've set a record
for how many we've been able
to squish into this space.
It's over 40 at this point.
So we have a few minutes
for questions.
I'm going to have to be
an evil time master today.
We have something else happening
in this room just a minute
or two after 1:00 o'clock.
So I see about 14 minutes
until 1:00 o'clock.
So --
>> Paul Miller: You're welcome
to email me any questions,
too, at McDaniel College.
You can find my email
address easily.
>> Grant Harris: So questions?
>> I guess just when you were
combining the novel Ragtime
with the real Houdini things, I
wasn't a hundred percent clear --
did Houdini in real life
actually say he had this warning
or was that --
>> Paul Miller: No.
>> -- in the novel?
>> Paul Miller: It's
completely fictional.
Yeah, yeah.
I did that on purpose because
it just kind of creates --
he wasn't hanging upside
down over Midtown.
He did that a lot, you know,
all over the world he did that.
But yeah.
>> [Inaudible] there were
other dukes in the world.
>> Paul Miller: Sorry?
>> There were hundreds of dukes.
>> Paul Miller: There were
other archdukes, right,
there were other heirs around.
But he was the heir, right?
He was --
>> Grant Harris: And for questions,
I'll just ask all of you to speak
up so that this gets
into the webcast
that will come in a few months.
>> Another French historian,
Mason, before you wrote this,
said that memory studies
in his [inaudible]
that history could
no longer be taught
to the current American generation
because they've lost the plot.
They don't understand it.
And the only way to penetrate
is shifting to memories.
>> Paul Miller: Well, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
In another piece that I've
written -- it's actually a podcast,
so I can give you the website for
that through Oxford University,
the first World War I series
-- I kind of argue that.
I say the sandwich story's
completely ridiculous.
You need the history.
Students need the history.
But because of the sandwich story,
the students remember the history.
And that's relevant.
And I say in the webcast I feel
sort of heretical saying this
as a historian, as an
academic historian,
but nonetheless I think that does.
But when my students,
when I tell them, "Oh, no,
that's completely fictional,"
they're shocked.
And I said, "It just so
happens that you've got the guy
for your professor this
semester who, you know,
did this webcast on
this very issue."
So it's kind of ironic.
Yeah.
>> I was thinking about your point
about the memory studies
being subjective.
And sometimes it's
actually objective as well
because when we write history about
memory, we're trying to be objective
about what people's real
memories are, right?
>> Paul Miller: Absolutely, yeah.
>> Get as much as we can.
>> Paul Miller: It's a good point.
>> Still being objective
when we're studying memories.
>> Paul Miller: Yeah.
>> And also, studying
subjective memory has gone
on way before thinking about the
memories of kings or, you know,
like [inaudible] have
always been [inaudible].
>> Paul Miller: Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, that's a great point, yeah.
Wendy?
>> I'd like to follow up on that
point about memory being objective
as well, mainly because
you have these memories,
but you're still trying
to make sense of them
in a way that's intelligible.
>> Paul Miller: Mm-hmm.
I guess you could say I'm using
memory as a catch-all term in a way.
I'm taking all these various
examples from literature, from film,
from monuments, things like this,
and grouping them all as memory.
And I'm studying them objectively
as a historian for meaning.
Like, you know, first victims
of the First World War,
something like that.
Right? And yet, in this paper,
I'm also incorporating what is
considered academic histories
and showing the ways in which
some of these mnemonic sayings,
and phrases, and ideas like that
the assassination was random have
filtered into history writing.
So I'm not so much
scorning history as pointing
out that history itself
has subjectivities built
into it, I guess you can say.
That's a great point, thank you.
>> [Inaudible] you
mentioned Fitzgerald,
how about Ernest Hemingway?
>> Paul Miller: Earnest Hemingway?
Does he have something on
the Sarajevo assassination?
>> He has writing on World War I.
>> Paul Miller: Yes, yes.
He has his famous -- yeah.
No, The Sun Also Rises is not
-- I'll call it -- right, right.
Farewell to Arms.
Farewell to Arms is
his novel on World War I,
but I don't think it mentions
the Sarajevo assassination.
If I'm wrong, I would love -- you
know, you bring up a good point,
actually, because how do you find
sources for a project like this?
I mean, I hadn't read F. Scott
Fitzgerald's short story before.
So first of all, if you don't have
an Internet, you're really hurting.
So this project would have been much
harder when I was a grad student
and the Internet didn't
exist, right?
Secondly, you meet people
who have references for you.
I make a reference in
something else I've written
to a philosopher, John Searle.
I happened to meet a
philosophy student in a gym
in Belgrade and he said, "Oh, yeah.
John Searle uses the assassination
to illustrate something
about intentionalism."
So these are the ways in
which I discover things.
And people at talks
often point out things.
There's a famous Nobel Prize-winning
Iceland writer, Halldor Laxness --
maybe some of you have
heard of him --
who references the Sarajevo
assassination in a funny way
because the World War I is
nothing but good for Iceland.
I mean, commerce really
picks up, trade.
This is true of US as well.
Until we actually get in
it, we profit tremendously.
So yeah. But I have
to look on Hemingway.
I'll Google "Hemingway Sarajevo,"
see if anything comes up.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Paul Miller: Okay.
Yes?
>> Was the decision by
the government to get rid
of those footsteps [inaudible]?
>> Paul Miller: Great question.
So what happened was the
footsteps were created
by Socialist Yugoslavia after 1945.
They were put in the pavement in
1953 and the museum was created.
In fact, Eleanor Roosevelt visited
the museum that summer and writes
about it in one of
her daily articles.
And in 1992 when the war
began, memory also divided.
So under Socialist Yugoslavia,
you had fraternity, you know,
the brotherhood -- unity and
brotherhood, right, jedinstvo --
why am I suddenly forgetting
the phrase?
Help me out here.
Bratstvo i jedinstvo, right,
brotherhood and unity.
What?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Paul Miller: Right, exactly.
Thank you.
Bratstvo i jedinstvo unity.
And then war began in 1992.
And all of a sudden the Bosnian
Muslims and Croats decided no,
the assassin was no great
hero because we were part
of Austria-Hungary back then,
and that was a great empire.
We were already in Europe, okay?
And he only is a hero today
for Serbs and Bosnian Serbs.
So we don't know what
happened to the footsteps.
There are various stories.
It seems they were torn out
of the pavement at some point
and then they disappeared.
After the war, there
was an effort to --
there were many different ideas
as to what we should
do with the site now.
One was to put the footprints back
because they don't necessarily have
to be worshipful in meaning, right?
They can just exist there.
And also have the huge monument
to Franz Ferdinand's wife
that was constructed by
the Austrians and dedicated
on June 28th, 1917 in
the middle of the war,
a year before Austria's
going to collapse.
Okay? And to put both of those --
and a part of that huge
memorial is actually
in the Sarajevo Art
Museum, you can go see it.
And that never happened.
But they did recast the footprints,
but they were never put back in.
And today there's a museum of
the Austro-Hungarian period.
And there's a plaque.
And the plaque could also be
discussed in terms of memory.
It basically says on
this place this happened.
But it's a memory device
telling you the history,
directly on this place
Gavrilo Princip shot
and killed the Archduke
Franz Ferdinand and his wife.
That's all it says.
And interestingly, rather than
being in Latin Serbo-Croatian
and Cyrillic Serbo-Croatian,
it's in English
and Serbo-Croatian in Latin letters.
So it's tourist-oriented.
>> And that museum is gone?
>> Paul Miller: No, it's
a new museum called --
the worshipful Princip part is gone.
In my estimation and in an
article I've written on the memory
in the former Yugoslavia --
in Yugoslavia and the
former Yugoslavia,
I argue that it has now
gone in the other direction
because there is a massive --
and inside when it was the
Princip Museum, there were busts
of Princip and he was glorified.
Now there's a huge, massive,
taller than a person statues
of Franz Ferdinand and his
wife in wax as they're coming
out of the city hall
into the sunlight
of their last living moments.
So I think you can interpret that.
And there's a beautiful portrait
of the pair and things like that.
So yeah.
>> Grant Harris: Anyone,
last question?
I will just add one thing
before we thank Paul.
Our specialist for the South
Slavic countries is Angela Cannon.
Angela, could you stand
just for a second
so we can all see your
sunbeam of a face?
And, Angela, do you have
any cards with you today?
Okay. Yeah, we do have really
incredible South Slavic collections,
and Angela is our curator for those.
If you have questions about the
collections, you want to get
in touch with her later or
now, do get her card from her.
Well, help me thank Paul again.
This was just incredible.
Thank you, Paul.
>> Paul Miller: Thanks for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.